I thought it was going to be like a
couple of people in the grass and we're
talking with speaking amongst each other
now this turned out to be bigger than
what we thought it was going to be this
program has worked well it has been
successful for the schools for the
parents and more importantly for the
children well right now some folks in
Congress want to end this program but
we're not going to accept that are we as
a parent I don't need the government
telling me what I can and cannot do when
it comes to the education of my child
genuine I'm here as a husband I'm here
as a father and I'm also here as a
concerned citizen I am Obama supporter
but people have their different issues
and people have their different ways of
going about things i'm pretty sure he
wants the best for his kids as every
parent want the best for their the whole
world is watching washington DC every
parent should have the right of choice
every parent should be able to choose
the best school for their children I
think that human rights I think our
opportunity I take a quality or
democratic issue this is why
everybody ought to be behind this
including Democrats I refuse refuse
refuse to be someone's inmate or charity
case you're putting all the disbelievers
in their place we need to fight for the
right to have our children educated so
we're sending the message not just to
our elected leadership the mayor and the
council we're sending a message to the
federal government the mother of our
movement Virginia Walden Ford is going
to take some parents she's going to walk
across the street and she's going to
present over 7,000 petitions of District
residents who support this program he
suddenly will look at him and I think he
will certainly think about the fact that
these are the voices of DC residents
these are his constituent we're seeing
the message that every child matters and
just like this nation was founded on the
notion that in order for a participatory
democracy to work the people must be
educated we have to make sure that our
people are educated we need to look at
the bigger picture once everybody's gone
out of the House Senate Congress we
still have to think about our future
which is our kids right now and that's
why I'm sitting here advocating the
rallies over but the cause is never
going to be over